It turns out that TCP is not a good fit for congestion control for streaming
video, or streaming audio. TCP retransmits lost packets,
but retransmissions may not always be useful. TCP
also slows down its sending rate after
packet loss, which may cause starvation of the
client. There's also a fair amount of overhead
in the protocol. A TCP header of 20
bytes for every packet is large for audio
samples. And sending acknowledgements for every other packet
may be more feedback than is needed. Instead,
one might consider using UDP. UDP does not retransmit
lost packets and it does not automatically adapt
the sending rate. It also has a smaller header.
Because UDP does not automatically retransmit packets or
adjust the sending rate, many things are left to
higher layers. Potentially the application, such as when
to transmit the data, how to encapsulate it, whether
to retransmit, and whether to adapt the sending
rate, or to adapt the quality of the video
or audio encoding. So higher layers must solve
these problems. In particular, the sending rate still needs
to be friendly or fair to other TCP senders,
which may be sharing the link. There are a
variety of video streaming and audio streaming transport
protocols that are built on top of UDP, that
allows senders to figure out when and how to
retransmit lost packets and how to adjust sending rates.